they are the pictures so many have
longed for years to see
taking her first steps back to freedom
after so long
for her husband richard and daughter
gabriela it was touch and go to the end
she wanted to come just to give me
support
we've seen the photos of mezzanine on
the plane um it's been a i mean a long
deal but obviously the last couple of
days where we've not been speaking
um it's been very up and down and it's
been getting closer and closer and
things moved on sunday
i mean a huge relief huge relief that
she's on a plane that she's coming home
that she's free and thank you
to everyone who's been helping along the
way it's been a long journey that people
have been keeping us
following it on the news
on petitions with the government
i've said some rough things over the
years
but in the end she's coming home
richard has campaigned relentlessly
waiting for the day he could tell his
daughter her mother's coming home
well i suppose that we can stop being a
moment in history and start being a
normal family again um yeah it's been a
long time um isn't it we were just
saying you know last night
gabrielle was asking is mommy really
coming back tomorrow i said well i don't
i don't know for sure i think we're
close to her
i mean i now know
pretty surely she is coming home
nazanin's ordeal began at the airport
where it ended she was leaving tehran
six years ago after a holiday
introducing her daughter to her parents
when iranian security moved in their
hidden camera catches her bewilderment
the chilling start to a hellish ordeal
the young british mother charged with
trying to topple iran's regime the
hardest bit to live with
was probably that early realization of
her sitting
in a windowless cell
being interrogated and blindfolded and
i've done nothing without it
i'm getting better at it before his
wife's release richard told me about
those terrifying early days he was urged
by the government to keep a low profile
he did the opposite while his wife
languished in an iranian jail he set
about trying to galvanize public support
and sympathy releasing photos we now
know so well campaigning and even hunger
striking because he says taking
government advice would only have made
his wife's ordeal much worse the
consequences are you get exposed to more
torture
given those consequences you know can
you with a straight face to be given
that advice
transparency
openness always protects you
the government's failure to secure
nazanin's release earlier will be the
subject of intense debate as she and
anushira shuri fly home though ministers
are claiming credit and offering support
my sympathies with the families for what
they've suffered over this appalling
time and i'm delighted to be welcoming
them back to the uk my family and i are
delighted to confirm that my dad has
been released and will be returning to
the uk today retired engineer anushara
shuri from lewisham has been held for
five years his family say they can't
wait to have him home we've missed doing
so many ordinary things together you
know we've missed birthdays we've missed
christmases
we've missed walking the dog uh taking a
simple holiday
you know sitting together drinking a cup
of coffee all of this uh is is we have
to start all over again the government's
also secured the release on furlough of
british citizen and retired
conservationist murad tabaz but there
are many other dual nationals from the
uk and elsewhere still left behind we
have succeeded in our journey but there
are people who are still where we were
yesterday and they don't know how long
they're going to be
on that journey of suffering and
frustrations
for nazaneen there have been so many
full storms hopes raised and dashed they
counted down the days to the end of a
first sentence only to have another one
imposed gabrielle has only known her
mother from a distance on video calls
but tonight their family will be
reunited together again at last
dominic waghorn sky news
[Music]